[Music]
big cat should have gone to Las Vegas
earlier this week if you'd been there
you could have placed a bet on Mitchell
true Biscay Bears quarterback for MVP at
200 to 1 odds within a matter of days
it was bet down to 50 to 1 so there is a
lot of belief out there in true Biscay
and the Bears and we know how the MVP
award goes it's often the best
quarterback on the best team that's it
and if you're on a team that has a great
season and you have decent numbers you
get consideration for MVP because you're
the leader of that great team we see
that fairly often and the Bears have all
the ingredients to be great this year
and if so true Biscay has all the
indications gonna step up in his second
year in Madden Aggies offense it really
could line up that way how do you know I
wasn't the guy who put in this bed I
love this this means someone smarter
than me in Las Vegas put a lot of money
on Mitch too risky to win MVP that makes
the my brain say okay well he probably
will win MVP because the people in Las
Vegas always win money those are the
guys the guys in the shadows who are
putting down these big bets or
alternatively Jim Belushi just got his
residual for whatever Oh
Jimbo I didn't expect the Jim Belushi
reference today but either way from 201
down to 50 to 1 and I believe in true
Biscay look I really
the thing about MVP there's nothing
objective about it you've got 50 voters
sports writers broadcasters and you know
it's it's it's basically a quarterback
award and it typically goes to the
quarterback from the best team and or at
least that person has a serious chance
to win it and I could see the Bears
being the best team in the NFL this year
i you know III yeah they could go the
other direction as well but I thought
what we saw last year was very promising
and I think that the offense will be
better and true Biscay will be better
and it's it's really not that crazy of a
bed at all yeah you're right it's best
team it's best story I think the NFL you
saw it last year the NFL wants the Bears
to be good they want Chicago meaning by
the end of the season it felt like the
Bears were on every primetime game and
if you look at the 2019 schedule
the Bears have so many prime time games
including the start to the season which
is rare that they don't start the season
with a Super Bowl champ they're starting
at Thursday Night Football with the
Bears and the Packers so mr. Biscay will
have the chances to have those MVP type
moments whether you're talking about
Thursday night Sunday night Monday night
the big marquee games a late afternoon
game on a Sunday he will have all these
moments and chances to kind of step up
in the American consciousness and that's
really what it is it's it's half good
team it's half being a quarterback and
then it's half so I'm now 150% half just
getting everyone to talk about you
having that Sports Illustrated story
about you having Mike Florio write a
bunch of blogs about you that means
something you know there's somebody else
out there who's gonna plenty of
opportunities to perform in primetime
with a team that you know we're gonna
see a lot this year in big moments he's
in the same division
he wears purple Kirk Cousins I wonder
what his odds are I don't think they're
I don't think they're they're 200 to 1 I
don't think he's flying that far under
the radar but I don't think it would be
a good bet either but you never know you
know that's the thing once they start
playing the games we get a feeling
within the first month or so how this is
going to go and even then it changes but
hey you know yeah at the end of the day
we feel like the Patriots are gonna be
in the mix but how we get there from
point A to point B through 17 weeks of
football who knows he could be Mitchell
to Biscay it could be Patrick my Holmes
he could beat Kirk Cousins it could be
somebody not thinking about it's not
good before I forget you called me out
last hour for pick and say qualm barkley
as the non quarterback most likely to
win the MVP and you suggested I was
taking liberties with the rules because
he was a 32100 aw he's 60 to 1 so he's
more of an underdog than the guy you
picked Christian McCaffrey so I'm
switching back to say Quan Barkley ok
great Kirk Cousins is infinity to 1 to
win the MVP in I still wouldn't vet that
even if I could win infinity I would not
put down the dollar
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports